seit 2012 waren sie als frau mal im
einsatz haben sich in der rockerszene
getarnt wie fühlt sich das ganze
ich bin damals auf das landeskriminalamt
nordrhein-westfalen zu gegangen ich
hatte bereits behördenkontakte und hatte
zu verschiedenen lks den kontakt seit
jahren als verbindungsmann und habe im
dezember 2011 mich für einen verdeckten
vor einsatz für das lka
nordrhein-westfalen im rocker milieu
oder in den arabischen clans
vorgeschlagen und wie kommt man damit
klar wenn man gar nicht über seine
arbeit sprechen kann das heißt sie
mussten ja doppelleben führen verdeckt
ermitteln sozusagen und können ja auch
nicht mit ihren freunden und ihrer
familie darüber sprechen vielleicht auch
aus angst wie geht man damit um
ja sie isolieren sich letzten endes
komplett von ihrem sozialen umfeld sie
haben keinerlei soziale kontakte
meine kontakte haben sich letzten endes
auf leute im alltag beschränken
beschränkt im fitnessstudio oder
vielleicht teilweise auch nur beim
einkaufen und sie werden zum klassischen
einzelgänger eben weil sie der
schweigepflicht unterliegen der
geheimhaltung unterliegen
und wenn sie 24 stunden die figur miga
nie spielen in der öffentlichkeit können
sie auch nicht an privat hingehen und
familie freunden oder vielleicht sogar
der eigenen freundin erklären wer sie in
wirklichkeit sind weil das ist verboten
und das dürfen sie nicht und sie haben
sich genauso an vorschriften und
verordnungen
und zu erhalten wie jeder andere auch
ich möchte mit meiner vergangenheit
aufräumen ich bin seit meiner
inhaftierung der rechtskräftigen
verurteilung natürlich nicht mehr
einsetzbar und habe letzten endes jetzt
auch für meine entscheidung gesorgt weil
ich der meinung bin dass ich gute
menschen in deutschland grundsätzlich
nicht zu verstecken haben ich habe meine
arbeit gemacht ich habe recht und
ordnung verteidigt ich habe dafür
gesorgt dass straftaten aufgeklärt
werden und auch verhindert werden
ich kann mich nur daran erinnern dass
ich in den 2009 13 jährige mädchen aus
bordellen befreit habe mit oder in
zusammenarbeit mit dem landeskriminalamt
hamburg und das sind für mich wichtige
dinge genauso wie wir
sprengstoffanschläge und mordanschläge
in duisburg damals im rotlichtviertel
verhindern konnten
mit der polizei duisburg zusammen und
dafür braucht man sich meiner meinung
nach in keinster weise zu schämen und
die paar kriminellen die wir hier in
diesem land haben
die sollten hier nicht die oberhand
bekommen heute sind ja kein fan mehr
erleben sie jetzt trotzdem ja
ungefährlich weil wer geht denn die
rockerszene auf ihren ausstieg und
generell auf dieses geständnis das sie
halt als v mann ermittelt haben
ich denke mal dass der opa bereich
besonders die rocker oder auch die
arabischen clans anderes zu tun haben
als einen ehemaligen v mann der polizei
zu verfolgen und eventuell dem irgendwas
anzutun ja fakt ist ich lebe hier immer
noch in einem rechtsstaat und ich bin
genauso in allen bereichen zu des
öffentlichen lebens anzutreffen in jeder
fußgängerzone in jedem urlaubsgebiet in
jedem einkaufsladen wie jeder andere
auch ich ziehe mir kann der sonnenbrille
auf ich verstecke mich nicht
oder oder
gehen nur noch nachts auf die straße wie
gesagt ich glaube an unseren rechtsstaat
und sollte es mal zu einer begegnung
kommen wird es mit sicherheit vielleicht
die eine oder andere diskussion geben
aber ich gehe da ganz und vorschauen mit
um weil wie gesagt ich bin der gute in
der geschichte